hi how are you right now how do you feel
ah she feels great how are you right
then she has to pee does she have to be
the excitement of it all how am i how
are you right now
I am grateful I am excited I am happy my
children I didn't thank HBO I have to
thank HBO okay yes everybody that works
between the roof and the lobby took such
good care of us yeah they took such good
care of our show yeah you said that this
speech you saved from 25 years doesn't
replace the people you just replaced
yeah no people are doing it was it was
it kind of the same speech with me now
you did thank your children though and
didn't your son help you with your max
max help with your vision he directed my
audition in my house and then the second
time when Bill called me back
yes oh I sent it to him of via email
script and he did it over the phone
honest honest to god you told me that
the way you under it be remembered is
that you were good to people yeah you
are nice to Pete yes that is true
all those years now and you have this
yes what does this say to you about you
and who you know what it doesn't I don't
think it says anything it doesn't define
me you know what it does it is a
reaffirmation that the dream I had that
is true I dreamt on the West Side of New
York in apartment 10 a when your dad
said don't do this and when I was seven
my father told me not to do this until I
became famous at which time he became
Zakho producer of end living and then I
didn't care Wow Wow
how's your wife and what'd she say she
was so proud
she broke her leg Stace I hope you're
feeling better you're out there by
yourself and look at that Ron Howard oh
my gosh yeah no what he he called me he
said look we haven't seen each other in
a long time I'm going to the Emmys I
hope we can hug and we did and you did
and you had a moment we did Wow have you
had a chance to talk to your kids yet no
but no I think maybe they they might
have texted me or something look at all
your phone
his phone is exploding well yeah I got
78 texts 78 texts since you just got
back here yeah I'm gonna call Matt I
gotta call max you got called oh this is
party as part of this moment you have to
call you okay wait a minute where's
Maxie
he's up in Boston now yeah directing his
third movie but working here I'm gonna
call me throwin on speaker okay
I'm very hungry are you you know winning
doesn't hello now you know he's
directing so he probably is not going to
answer so he's busy working yeah he and
he doesn't give a key doesn't care about
his dad
no I don't know what is hat
this is it when I do hi Maxie we're on
et and I just wanted to say thank you
for directing my audition cuz you I hear
I am your dad wad oh my god
your dad was dad one I'm hearing a baby
yeah thank you I love you sweetie have a
good time all right
wow that's pretty cool though come on
it's pretty cool yeah so which is now
say to that guy who was the Fonz and you
talked about that you you know you
thought about maybe this wasn't the
right profession for you what would you
say to that guy now she relaxed I would
say relax I was so nervous at that time
as a human being yes that I was awkward
and it has taken me all this time to
grow into myself so a young actor I
would tell them that they must just
relax into who they are and be authentic
and by the way you win bill wins how
about that there's a little heat on your
show right now
whoa can you guys read Nicole you're
looking there goes bill right now bill
come here come here come here just
celebrate with my boss this man created
he writes he directs he produces and he
stars among us
Bill Hader hi Henry we have to work on
Wednesday you know that right I'll do
what I'm so excited we have at 7:00 a.m.
did you win an Emmy yes oh yeah and we
do Barry together we do Barry together
will you tell everybody I love you will
you guys take those things to work with
you I know we're not gonna push it and
by the way we're gonna get there on
Wednesday and look at each other going
what are we doing I don't know what we
have a whole second just because just
because we have this doesn't mean we're
suddenly like not and
like oh no I don't know what we're doing
in season 2 yes oh no it's good but he
wrote with he and and Alec and and
they're great writers they have written
I think all the scripts yeah yeah I just
got revisions on on the fourth episode
and all the way to the fourth episode
yeah yeah no we're getting there man but
this guy makes makes me look good so I'm
very lucky see I was gonna say look at
you too it's a great act I'll tell you
Bill congratulations how about that how
are you gonna celebrate tonight how will
you celebrate do you know what the first
thing I'm gonna do yeah let's take a
shower because it is hot are you HOT I
went upstairs and change my shirt Wow
we're we're sweating yeah how am I gonna
celebrate I'm gonna call my children
yeah I honestly I'm gonna call my
children they have been with me you know
when I said kids you can go to sleep now
daddy one they're 35 36 and 45 years old
you know about what I wrote that
originally 43 years ago so it works out
now it works out today did but I'm work
yeah by the time they get the
information they'll go to bed it's true
it is great I mean there is nothing
better than to see good people and I'm
gonna tell you something you are one of
the best and this is a marvelous moment
well we always like a great conversation
yeah but you're a good man really
[Music]
[Applause]